thank you so much
[Applause]
good afternoon
thank you so much good afternoon good
afternoon my fellow my fellow unionists
when as I speak to you of course as a
proud representative of the conservative
and unionist party I want to begin
quickly by thanking my friend
Christopher Moran for everything he does
for Northern Ireland helping me to
secure this invitation and I want to
thank the people of Northern Ireland who
helped me to deliver an absolutely
crucial political promises has just been
mentioned because it was more than 10
years ago that I was cycling along Hoban
and I was almost crushed by a bendy bus
so long and so patiently unsuited to the
streets of London that I vowed there and
then to get elected mayor just to remove
it and at the same time to remove from
office the left-wing IRA sympathizing
united Ireland promoting semi Marxist
who then inhabited City Hall and we
[Music]
we defeated this representative of the
old London hard left and we got those
German manufactured bendy buses off the
streets instead we commissioned a
vehicle that has become an icon a piece
of design that was featured in Bond
films and is used reflexively to
identify the hip modern thriving
multicultural funk Appleton
City of London and with its seats made
in Telford its destination blinds from
Manchester its flooring from list card
its engines from Darlington its
wheelchair ramps from HOD stone in
hartfordshire
it would already be pretty
representative of this country but when
you consider that it was conceived
designed and assembled here in Northern
Ireland in Ballymena by right bus I
believe I believe that bus is the United
Kingdom or wheels whenever you see one
of these noble elephant Brown beasts you
are looking at a piece of Northern
Ireland in London so I want to say thank
you to the workforce in Palomino
today and I of course particular one to
thank our friends in the dup in the last
18 months you have supplied nigel arlene
all of you the essential components the
fuel wheels the pick your metaphor your
vehicular metaphor without which the
government of the United Kingdom could
not have been carried on without you it
is likely that the mighty engine of the
UK economy would have stuttered and
stalled and indeed if it wasn't for you
then there is a risk that the Union
itself would have been placed in
jeopardy and we all know why the DUP has
been so crucial because there really was
a danger after that election in June
last year that the government of the
whole UK could have been handed over to
Jeremy Corbyn
man whose economic policies would mean
ruin for this country pointless Leary
nationalizing businesses at a cost to
the taxpayer of hundreds of billions of
pounds recklessly expropriating 10% of
the equity of companies across the land
a Labour leader who with his putative
Chancellor John McDonald actually
believes that the real problem with the
Venezuelan economy is that Hugo Chavez
was not able to implement the entirety
of his demented socialist agenda and as
if that were not bad enough this is a
man who with his ally actually his ideas
of puppetmaster MacDonald there's not
only campaigned for a united Ireland but
to the best of my knowledge has failed
to condemn the terrorist atrocities of
the IRA and it's thanks to that
arrangement between our two parties
which Philip haven't spoke last night
quite rightly that we were able to stop
him to stop
Corbin from taking over and today we're
looking there for the whole country that
is benefiting from sensible moderate one
nation Conservative government we have
unemployment running at the lowest level
since 1975 we have real wage growth at
last we have the deficit falling and the
UK once again one of the fastest growing
economies in Europe so I say to our
allies in the dup thank you for your
courageous and principled stance and I
hope you agree that it is absolutely
vital that we keep this partnership
going and we keep this confidence and
supply arrangement going and that we are
not so complacent as to abandon the
government of this country to a man
whose avowed policy is to break up this
country and so we should work together
to ensure that the whole UK Northern
Ireland included can seize the
opportunities of Breton now you've heard
already from Nigel you're gonna hear
from all the others with warmer that for
Arlene and I don't I don't want to I
don't I don't want to anticipate what
she's gonna say I I keep seeing that
song to my song we are we are we are on
the verge we are on the verge of making
we are on the verge of making a historic
mistake and I just say this unless we
change course we are gonna stay in the
customs union we're gonna stay in the
single market we're gonna be rules
takers and unless we junk this back stop
we are going to find the brussels has
got us exactly where they want us
a satellite state we will we will
continue to accept the terms under which
they have a surplus in in trading goods
with us of 95 billion pounds but with no
power no British influence on those
terms and so we won't be able to do any
trade deals of any significance or any
value but this is what they've done in
Brussels is a very very clever trick
they've made Northern Ireland their
indispensable bargaining chip in the
future negotiations and if you read how
do you who's read the withdrawal
agreement I have unlike certain naval
leaders I can mention if you read the
withdrawal agreement you can see that
we're actually witnessing the birth of a
new country called UK brackets and I
Hockney read it seriously there's how
Brussels sees it acne is no longer
exclusively ruled by London or Stormont
acne is in large part to be ruled by
Brussels and acne will have to accept
large swathe of UK
EU regulations I wish was going to say
except UK raising EU regulations now and
in the future on the whole range of of
Brussels policy making lawn mower noise
labeling of sardines on the use of
chocolate coins and tokens that may be
deemed to resemble a euro on the EU's
I kid you not check it out on the use of
personal recreational watercraft now of
course nowhere has a more illustrious
history than Northern Ireland when it
comes to the building of recreational
watercraft
the Titanic Springs de Meyer and now is
the time to point out the iceberg ahead
because these obligations won't just
apply to current EU regulations but to
anything Brussels devises in the future
so do I mean to be perfectly serious I
suppose a Northern Irish inventor and
where to come up with a as possible
might were to come up with a with an
example of a personal recreational
watercraft that was perfectly safe but
in some way revolutionary or
cost-cutting or whatever a Northern
Irish peddler will paddleboard or
whatever it happened to be that
threatens to demolish the competitors in
Italy old or Germany for them you could
imagine such a circumstance then it will
be all too likely all too likely as we
saw by the way with James Dyson and his
hairdryers remember what happened and
his vacuum cleaners that the Brussels
Commission under pressure from the lobby
groups on the continent will legislate
in such a way as to band make an
economic that UK invention and not not
just for sale in the remainder of the EU
of course not but they will ban it for
sale in Northern Ireland as well and so
as a as a country as the United Kingdom
we will be faced with a Hobson's choice
if we wanted to do we genuinely wanted
to do free trade deals if you wanted to
cut tariffs on as we should by the way
on food from to make food cheaper for
our people for from sub-saharan Africa
or whatever he wanted to vary our
regulation then we would have to leave
Northern Ireland
behind as an economic semi colony of the
EU and we would be damaging the fabric
of the union with regulatory checks and
even customs controls between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland on top of
those extra regulatory checks down the
Irish Sea that are already envisaged in
the withdrawal agreement now I have to
tell you no
British Conservative government could or
should sign up to any such arrangement
[Applause]
and so our answer at the moment is
rather desperately to make sure that the
whole of the UK stays in the back stock
with the EU having the power to decide
whether or and when we can ever leave
why should they grant us permission to
leave lemmi what ask you why should they
will have handed over the 39 billion
pounds and it's not in their interest to
see us going off and doing those free
trade deals and they don't see Goods
coming in from third countries
undercutting undercutting their vast
exports to the UK so think to yourselves
what price will they ask in the
forthcoming negotiations for giving us
that freedom to leave the backstop they
might very well ask us for a special
deal on immigration so making a further
nonsense brexit they married asked us to
accept the whole gamut of EU legislation
on services as well as Goods and Agri
foods and all the level playing field
commitments that we have already made
and have committed to make in the future
as well
in other words this deal risks further
economic and political humiliation and
we are locking ourselves by treaty and
making it impossible to negotiate our
way out in the second half of the talks
this is not what the people of the
United Kingdom voted for it is
self-evidently not taking back control
of our laws it is not taking back
control of our borders not when we're
still collecting EU tariffs and sending
80% of the value of them to Brussels and
it remains to be seen quite how much of
our money we will really control and how
much they will charge for this
arrangement and if we go down this route
I have to warn you that the people of
our country will Rumble it and they will
detect that this is not brexit and that
by the way is the surest way to invite
in
through revenge and to run the risk I'm
afraid of a Corbin government that's the
risk we run so we need to get out of
this hole and people say we there isn't
a plan the course is a plan it's been
mentioned many many times here is what
we do
number one we need of course to bank
what is sensible in the withdrawal
agreement the good progress that has
been made on the rights of citizens the
rights of workers mutual recognition of
professional qualifications fair and
reasonable deal on benefits now that was
in any serious dangers a political
declaration also contains a lot of good
sense about our continuing policy
coordination with our friends and
partners across the channel on Home
Affairs counterterrorism foreign policy
and all the rest of it as the Prime
Minister rightly said this week she said
it many times and she's always right but
on this point
she's always right on this point we are
leaving the EU or we are not leaving
Europe and under any circumstances I
know it will be your way from it is my
profound wish that we will have a deep
intimate and productive friendship and
partnership with our friends in the EU
but we do need to junk the backstop and
agree
and agree that neither side will
introduce a hard border in Northern
Ireland both governments London Dublin
and Brussels have already made clear
they have no such intention Michel
Barnier has said himself that the
technical solutions exist and that the
whole subject should be remitted to
where it properly belongs in the
discussion on the future economic
partnership that will take place next
year we need at the same time to agree
in the withdrawal agreement that we all
have a big generous free trade agreement
on what they call super Canada lines and
we should dedicate the so-called
implementation period to getting those
negotiations right that leaves almost
two years and that should be plenty of
time to do a zero terrible zero quota
trade deal given that we start from a
position of zero tariffs and zero quotas
point four you can't even point for we
should I'm afraid withhold at least half
at least half of the cash were about to
pony up
until until the free trade agreement is
concluded at the end of 2020 I have
never known a major EU negotiation not
to conclude with the financial
settlement and we need to restore the
proper order and incentives to the
tall's fifth we need a secretary of
state for the United Kingdom for what
they call No Deal or rather exiting on
WTO terms a department with real powers
across Whitehall to make things happen I
don't believe that we will exit without
a deal I think that's totally
unnecessary but it is only responsible
of the government to make proper
preparations and lastly six we need
urgently as a country to recover our
confidence and our self belief and to
stop treating brexit as if it were a
plague of frogs or a moraine on our
cattle or some adverse weather event
that has to be managed brexit presents
massive opportunities to escape a
European model whose signature economic
project after all is the Euro that is
still causing 35% of the people of
Greece to be an absolute poverty and
grossly unnecessary unemployment in much
of the EU a European economic model
whose regulatory overload according to
Peter Mandelson and Gordon Brown no less
cost about five to seven percent of EU
GDP we need to have the courage and the
self belief to do things differently if
we want to and if we need to the UK is
the fifth biggest economy in the world
under this Conservative government we
are putting in record levels of
infrastructure investment we're putting
in the roads the rail the housing the
bridges and the power stations to give
business the platform for growth and
investment and by the way now is the
time I think to progress the admirable
suggestions
of Professor Alan Dunlop of Liverpool
University I think I think I saw my
friend Karen Bradley supporting him last
night and develop plans for a bridge
between Scotland and Northern Ireland
[Applause]
the vision reach what is it 19 20 miles
you in the visionary leadership of the
DUP has already been urging for some
time it is a far shorter distance than
that covered by some bridges around the
world you from France Shanghai to Ningbo
for instance the problem isn't
Beaufort's dike or whatever this dike
under under the water the problem isn't
the lack of funds the problem is an
absence of political will and what you
need in addition to the leadership of
the DEP on this matter I'm afraid you
also need strong regional government to
drive such projects I remember that you
that's what you needed in London to get
projects like Crossrail done and I hope
therefore that Stormont can be revived
as fast as possible I really do and I
know their difficulties I know there are
compromises that Emir but I really hope
they can happen because you need that
regional Dublin as a champion for
investment and commitment to this great
part of the United Kingdom and I'm
nobody can doubt looking at what you've
done it last euro sir
nobody can doubt the effectiveness of
the DUP in chiseling running out of the
territory you know I as a former mayor I
like your style
but there is much more to be done and
may I say that it must be done on behalf
and with the active support of all the
people of Northern Ireland all the
communities of Northern Ireland and if
we continue to make those investments
throughout this country then I as I say
will create the the seedbed for business
to flower and if we get the right brexit
deal we give us freedom to trade to
innovate as an entire whole an entire
United Kingdom then we can turbocharged
the areas in which this country already
leads Europe if not the world and I'm
delighted to say the right bus already
sells its products to China and India
and see in fact that a large part of my
time as foreign secretary trying to sell
right busses I did quite right we saw we
sold the and when I was mayor I think we
sweet we definitely make did a few deals
we sold the bendy buses I to to someone
else we saw the bendy buses to Malta
where they all they did I'm afraid they
jackknifed and and caught fire it was
was raised with me by the Maltese when I
think how much more we could do think
how much more we could do if we do
genuinely go ahead with those free trade
deals that not only cut the cost of food
and textiles and shoes for people in
this country but which would open up
markets for Northern Ireland products
for UK products around the world at a
time when free trade needs a powerful
global champion and when people rather
one I can tell you a yearning for us in
the United Kingdom to play that role
this is the moment this is our moment to
play to our strengths and to maximize
those strengths with our regulatory
approach we have such fantastic
advantages in this country the biggest
Sector anywhere in this hemisphere the
biggest financial sector by far the best
universities have more Nobel Prizes a
point I think I made in in in in in
Russia we have more Nobel Prizes from
one Cambridge cottage than from Russia
and China combined I think in think I
made the point in China as well but
nevermind it's true for one Cambridge
College in Russia and China combined we
have by far the most dynamic and
creative culture and media industries
let me ask you if you can remember last
year's seems a distant memory but can
you remember which was the biggest
grossing movie of 2017 anybody went with
around the world the beasts grossing
movie around the world of 2017 was okay
with Star Wars whatever they're not
whatever it was called it was the latest
edition of Star Wars beware does George
Lucas propose to make the follow-up
biopic of the life of obi-wan Kenobi
anybody know you've been following this
speech here in here in Northern Ireland
but can anybody remember what the net
what is the name of the weapon so
famously wielded by Obi one the robbing
enigmatic humming thing
it is a lightsaber a lightsaber and
where did they make the first lightsaber
ladies and gentlemen does anybody know
where they made the first labor where
was the grab of the lightsaber born
are you a year now I can tell you the
lightsaber the the lightsaber the
lightsaber was first created in my own
constituency Oxbridge and south Ruislip
so take the scenic splendor and
cinematic expertise of northern ireland
add back to the sheer raw inventiveness
of Oxbridge and you have the creative
genius of the whole united kingdom the
only
[Music]
the only country to be a net exporter of
music to the United States and in the
words of that great Northern Irish
singer
Van Morrison so that it is time we all
moved from the dark end of the street to
the bright side of the road
and if you have that tune going around
in your heads for the rest of the
afternoon and I'll have done my job we
have time to get this right believe me
we have time to get this right we have
an absolute duty to get this right and I
hope that we conservatives can continue
to work with you as proud and passionate
unionists backing our union against all
those who would seek to divide us and
believing in our amazing and ingenious
United Kingdom and if what we can do
together thank you very much
the Democratic People's Party is
delivering for everyone in Northern
Ireland our influence at Westminster was
able to secure an additional 1 billion
Pines for Northern Ireland and last
month's budget the Belfast reaching
studied a proposal Pakistan that is why
the DEP ensured that the proposal was a
very part of the competence of supply
agreement this is why there was an
announcement in the budget statement of
350 million Pines which will enable
proposal to get off the ground this will
mean investment jobs investing in
infrastructure 20,000 new jobs family
not just Belfast City Center but a wider
region from Ballymena straight to
campaign in the aftermath of the tragic
Primark fire our businesses and
retailers and Belfast le centre are
struggling that is why I along with my
DEP colleagues in Belfast went to the
Chancellor to request additional funds
to support our city centre
I am pleased that the Chancellor listen
to what we have to say I was able to
secure two million pints of additional
funds towards this much-needed support
while others boycott the de Pays
influence and hard work and Westminster
is delivering for all right across
northern Adams whether it's in Belfast
or securing progress for the city date
for Easter body mellony berryy the
drawdown of 300 million plans for shared
education additional money for health
and education and is the daily page that
is working to build a better and
brighter future for all in Northern
Ireland ladies Nealon just two minutes
to the next speaker please take your
seats two minutes
two weeks ago as a nation we paused
along with people around the world to
mark the 100th anniversary of the
armistice between the Allies and Germany
bringing an end to the Great War it is
right that we pay tribute to the service
and the sacrifice of those who gave so
much essentially though they served with
honor courage and commitment just as all
those we serve law enforcement today do
so well the Armed Forces problem is our
nation's commitment to those who serve
in our armed forces
it is a pledge but those who set self
aside for steel will not be
disadvantaged poison